[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know, with the advent of
the commercial space revolution,
with the fact that
human beings are finally
going to domesticate
space travel,
it's worth celebrating
for once why
we want to explore the
heavens to begin with.
And Marina Benjamin
perhaps has the best line.
She says, "When
we dream of space,
we dream of transcendence.
We dream of what
we might become."
The exploratory
journey, that desire
to break through
boundaries, to probe
the perimeters of
possibility, to explore
the adjacent possible-- that
is what it means to be human.
"We didn't stay in the
caves," says Kurzweil.
"We didn't stay on the planet."
With biotechnology,
we won't stay
with the limitations of biology.
In fact, today, by leveraging
exponentially emerging
technologies, we're going
to have computers trillions
of times more powerful
navigating spaceships
that are millions of times
cheaper taking us to space.
Richard Branson's
Virgin Galactic
is going to take
artists into space.
What's going to happen when
poets and artists look down
upon the Earth?
What new reflections that
will uplift the human spirit,
that will thrust
human consciousness
towards the numinous,
might transpire
when we keep pushing
beyond all limits, when
we get to Kubrick's
beyond the infinite,
the place where dreams are
born, through the wormhole,
down the rabbit hole.
It's glorious.
It's what Neil
deGrasse Tyson says.
"Doing what's never been
done before is intellectually
seductive, whether or not
we deem it practical."
It's what we do.
It's what makes us cosmic
heroes, cosmic revolutionaries,
not stooges
conscripted to advance
a natural order
that kills everyone.
So let us go forth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]